η προσωπική δοολοφωνι να θέμαμε το ερώτημα είναιμη θα οδιηγηθεί ένα νολόκλη μια ολόκληρη ένα
ολόκλιον κράτος σε μια καταστροφηκή μπορεία τέεμείς πρέπει να βλέπουμε τα θέματα ψυχράτούτε και να
βλέπουμε ψηχρά δεν μπορούμε να επηργάσουμε τ ότι γίνεται σ ούτε τ ότι γίνεται στο
ιράν ούτε το ότι θα αποφασίσει στην αμερική ούτε εκείνα δεν μπορούμε να επηράσουμε καινό
που μπορούμε να κάνυμε να διευκολύνουμε αυτό που κάνουμε εκαίομου μπορομε να κάνουμε να προγραμματιστούμε
για τρομοκρατία για μίωσυ τις ανάψυξη ας για πληθωρισμό για ενεργιακά προβλήματα αυτά τα για
τουριστικόγια τγια το τουριστικό τουρίμε που σύουραμε όλα όσαακούγονται ίσως υπάρξεις θα ήθελα να δώ
εγώ πόυ την κυέρνεισ ας πούμε τούν την περίοδο μια καπάνια προς τις επιχειρήσεις να
ξαναδούν την εφωδιαστική τους αλυσίδα λομό τις κατάασταρης λόγο της κατάστασης υπάρχει πιθανότητα να έχουμε
προβλήματα μιλούμε πώς μπορά κληση η εμένη μπορί κληση το σουές η φωδιαστική αλυσίδα εσείς
συμμασία πρέπει να δούμε κάποια πράγματα προνοητικά μπορείς γιαως την πένα πο να αυκή εκποπή
να μετα προνορητικά ν μετά τρο λεγώ όμως εγώ θα ήθελα να δώ που ην
κυβέρνηση μια ντέθια ενέργια νάρα για να σωπαντήσω ξεκαθαρατην ερωτήσει καλά κάμνι η κυβέρνηση γενικά
στην εξωτερική μας πολιτική να είμαστε όντως εδώ κα να είμαστε μπαρόντες πρέπει να διασφαλήσει
όσο γίνεται όσο μπορεί τη μη εμπλοκ μας αλλά να μη χάσουμε το σημαχικό μας
ρόλο με τους με τις φίλες χώρες